[Musik]
feststellen dass auf demokratischen weg
wirkt sich dieses land in die irre
geführt wurde und es ist jetzt die
verantwortung der britischen regierung
und auch der eu dass sie letztlich keine
lösung gefunden und was das parlament
will erschließt sich einig also cent
gegen das abkommen
auch beim zu setzen sie dagegen sie sind
gegen einen neuen volksentscheid das
haben sie klar bestimmt sie sind aber
auch gegen einen harten briggs ist
sondern sie wollen ein deal aber wer
soll das eigentlich viel aushandeln und
wie kommen sie darauf dass die 27 an
anwenden also sich auf einen völlig
anderen vertrag einlassen ich glaube die
bürger haben noch nicht begriffen dass
sie keine weltmacht mir sind wird der
vertrag von mye am ende noch einmal
abgestimmt
ja wahrscheinlich wird hier nichts
anderes übrig bleiben aber im augenblick
sage ich ihnen läuft alles auf einen
knallharten briggs ist raus und ob sie
sich mit der verschiebung von gefallen
tun weiß ich auch nicht weil die
wirtschaft immer unsicherer wird das hat
ja dann auch alles konsequenzen auch für
großbritannien
wir kriegen er jetzt schon
staatsbürgerschafts anträge vor dem
briten fast jetzt früher überhaupt nicht
kannten
und da glaube ich nur neue
beamtenstellen immerhin schafft es einen
job und welche direkten folgen oder oder
konsequenzen hatte er brächte für europa
wie kann europa reagieren und das
vertrauen der der europäer in die
europäischen institutionen ihre stärker
machen nachdem presse naja wir müssen
die eu gründlich verändern
sie muss demokratischer sozial gerecht
ökologisch nachhaltiger werden
wir brauchen auch ein stärkeres
europäisches parlament im verhältnis zu
kommission wissen die regierung
versuchen immer so eine art
regierungsviertel realismus daraus zu
machen aber alles sind parlamentarische
demokratie
das muss man sehen die sozialen
grundrechte sind leider nicht einklagbar
dadurch ist die rechtsprechung des
europäischen gerichtshofs so einseitig
weil sie über das andere gar nicht
entscheiden dürfen auch bei den
menschenrechten nicht
da dürfen sie über soziale rechte wieder
nicht entscheiden sondern nur über
politische das alles muss man verändern
wenn man die eu attraktiver machen will
und außerdem müssen die politiker in den
ländern auch in deutschland aufhören
immer wenn sie etwas machen was den
leuten nicht gefällt es auf brüssel zu
schieben
in der hälfte der fälle wird stimmen in
der anderen hälfte ist es frei erfunden
und die leute können es überhaupt nicht
nach kontrolliert und dadurch entsteht
zu negativer ruf wissen sie auch dass
muss man korrigieren und dann müssen wir
auf alle parteien haben schwierigkeiten
was europa betrifft auch meine wobei die
mehrheitsmeinung das hat herr parteitag
gezeigt eindeutig ist wir wollen die
europäische integration wir wollen
internationalistisch an die fragen
herangehen
das scheint mir auch ganz wichtig zu
sein vereine gibt es doch viele dinge
die sind doch national gar nicht mehr zu
regeln wie soll ich denn das klima
national retten wie soll ich denn die
europäischen konzerne nationalstaatlich
regulieren die soziale frage ist eher
eine menschheitsfrage worden das heißt
natürlich ski dies können wir national
machen aber vieles müssen wir eben auch
international machen und die europäische
union ist ja ein einmaliges konstrukt
sonst gibt es ja so was auf der erde gar
nicht und deshalb sage ich immer die
alten sind verpflichtet für die jugend
die europäische integration zu retten
aus gründen des friedens aber auch aus
gründen der mobilität diese jugend reist
doch durch den ganzen kontinent sie
arbeiten man da sie lernen hier und dort
zu sprechen ganz gut englisch wenn wir
den sachen zurück zum alten
nationalstaat mit trends kommen und pass
denken ja wir haben eine meise also mit
anderen worten es bleibt viel zu tun
bitte
[Musik]